echánove como esta bienvenido a radio
canadá internacional
muchas gracias hoy estoy bien estoy bien
es un gusto que haya aceptado esta
entrevista usted va a ser parte de un
evento se llama en español que se
llamaría en español si lo traducimos el
flamenco en todas sus formas que es una
conferencia pero también habrá baile y
también habla habrá canto usted es
compositor y no sé si decir cantante o
cantaor
gracias por preguntar en realidad
en realidad sí cuando canto flamenco me
tengo que presentar como cantado pero es
verdad que también tengo todo el
repertorio de composiciones personales
varios idiomas y en ese caso también no
me definiría como como cantado pero más
bien como cantautor cantautor no sé muy
bien mezclado eso es bueno siempre
hacerse preguntas sobre su identidad nos
lleva a muchas cosas interesantes
siempre dígame álvaro en qué va a
consistir este evento como tal nos dice
va a haber música va a haber danza baile
baile pues iba también haber una parte
lúdica es una parte de pedagogía
entonces cuéntenos en qué va a consistir
más o menos sin contarnos todo todo todo
pero más o menos en qué va a consistir
pues si es simplemente presentamos un
poco nuestra
la historia del flamenco la las las
formas del flamenco las diferentes
formas que puede tomar el flamenco de
manera bueno no quiero decir la
académica porque el flamenco y la
academia no funcionan bien juntos pero
en todo caso lo vamos a presentar para
un único que lo que no está descubriendo
porque sabemos que estamos muy viejos
[Música]
una del flamenco que se andalucía así
que presentamos el flamenco pues como
para la persona que nunca que no lo
conoce bien o que ha oído la palabra que
ha escuchado la palabra que tiene una
idea de lo que es pero nosotros
clarificamos un poco ponemos unas pautas
en la historia de geografía y de
musicales también
y pues ya cada vez demostrando con
ejemplos lo que queremos decir
vamos a hablar de diferentes estilos del
flamenco ya cada vez enseñando con un
cante o con una pieza de víctor agrade
la guitarrista que amorím bloque
[Música]
eso
y el escenario de donde van a estar
ustedes porque me imagino que ustedes sí
estarán juntos en el mismo lugar no de
acuerdo entonces usted y delfín manta y
terol implante van a estar en un mismo
espacio será en donde él en el museo
mismo que en la sal murió en la sala
brooks y es verdad de acuerdo estos van
a estar ahí
y todo va a ser difundido a través del
internet como ahora ya estamos tan
acostumbrados a consumir cultura y
consumir toda clase de cosas a través
del internet virtualmente pues y
entonces yo no quisiera que nos contara
qué es lo que piensa sobre el mundo del
flamenco en montreal porque yo he
descubierto yo yo fui a andalucía y
conocí a conocer flamenco de cerca
digamos en su casa pero también he visto
un auge muy interesante del flamenco
haciendo entregas entonces pero me
gustaría tener su opinión de alguien que
conoce realmente esto entonces qué le
parece pues yo amo
es una comunidad bella de gente
apasionada por por un arte que estaba
muy arraigado en en andalucía
la gente de aquí lo reconoce y al mismo
tiempo ha puesto creativa con todo el
respeto que se debe a una cultura tan
tan honda tanto tan antigua que yo
siempre digo que el flamenco es un poco
como el como lo como el sushi no el para
comer pues aquí se pueden en canadá
moral o en parís se pueden comer buenos
su signo pero para comer el sushi para
encontrar para probar el sushi auténtico
más más más elegante más equilibrado o
más perfecto hay que ir a japón eso pero
eso no quiere decir que no pueda haber
sushi interesante gracioso sabroso en
otro sitio del mundo y eso es lo que
estamos intentando hacer en moderar
además porque muy bien está la comunidad
flamenca de mundial está encabezada por
por por unas figuras que han estudiado
muchísimo el flamenco que han pasado
mucho tiempo
tierra española para estudiarlo con los
grandes maestros y resulta que pues
estoy pensando ahora mismo en la que
será nuestra guitarrista en el museo de
bellas artes que es que aún no que es
una persona que tiene una experiencia en
el flamenco y un reconocimiento por
parte de la comunidad flamenca española
que es muy grande y delfín monta también
como bailaora se lo ha como como decimos
los madrileños se lo ha currado ha
pasado mucho tiempo en en madrid y en
sevilla así que esa gente pues se ha
traído a traigo su conocimiento a mover
al para para difundirlo aquí y nada y se
crean pues comunidades un poco
alternativas de aficionados
[Música]
que nada que encuentran que se
hablábamos un poco de identidad al
principio pues aquí la gente está como
negociando un poco son bienvenida
condensada con esa fuente esa fuente de
arte andaluza ese es muy interesante ver
cómo la gente hace hoy en día se puede
ser de varios sitios corazón jerezano
pero haber nacido ahora estamos todos
hechos de varios sistemas diferentes y
en el medio de todos ellos sé que somos
quienes somos y vamos evolucionando yo
estamos un poco más de un lado como del
otro pero somos todo eso entonces bueno
algo era alma no les deseo mucha suerte
me parece que va a ser algo lindo le
agradezco mucho quería tomar tiempo
conversar con nosotros hoy y suéteres
que les vaya muy bien
muchísimas gracias
hasta el fondo con tono
[Música]